Hey, good afternoon, Brandy.
Hey, Gagan, I'm so sorry I'm late. We had some emergencies come up internally that I was dealing with.
Oh, I'm sorry to hear that. Do you still need to attend that or is it a good time to continue with this call?
Nope, we can go now.
Okay, thank you. But I truly appreciate that you still made it to this call. Okay.
And.
Yeah.
Kevin, anything from your end before we start?
No, Gagan, thank you, Brandy, for joining in. We truly appreciate it. So, Gagan, let's start the show.
Yeah.
S.
Thank you. I hope you're feeling better from flu than you had yesterday. Yesterday on the yesterday means on the previous call. Thank you.
Much better, thank you.
It feels like yesterday.
Yeah, absolutely. Thank you. Okay, as you know, the purpose of this call is only to ensure that we are moving towards the right direction. And if anything that needs attention, you know, we are aware of that and so that we can fix those things beforehand.
Mm.
Thank Yu.
And give you a smooth and seamless experience with ITBD. Thank you, so...
Once again, welcome to this call and happy Monday. Sharing my screen, let me know once it's visible on your screens in a few seconds.
I can see it.
Thank you. So excuse me for my dry cough. You know, I had some peanuts, which is why I mean, I drank water, you know, over it. So feeling a little dry cough. So excuse me for that. All right, so Team, this is from April 27th to May 4th, which was the last week.
Mm.
Agenda items, nothing is nothing has changed, so we have highlights. I'll just quickly walk you through. You know, in the interest of time, I know. I mean, if you may have extra time, 5 words extra extra, because I'm in a meeting started late, so please excuse us for that. So, we have ITBD service offerings.
AI by design, holiday schedule that we always show, way forward with uptime USA, and a recap that we share after this call via email. And again, I don't have to say it, but that's my drill, so please feel free to, you know, chime in.
And let us know if you have any feedback or insights about the slides and anything that you're in that you might have observed.
Mhm.
These are a few of the highlights that I captured. So Shiv depicted positive improvement in his utilization during this period, which we'll be reviewing on the following slides. And so I was doing board reviews with them that, you know, how they are picking up.
their pace with the task they are getting. So, VB and Chip, they both are consistent in handling end user support, 365 and Addy related ticket. These are some of the major call drivers that they are handling. But I would like to hear from you as well. If you think.
Mhm.
they need to step up to something else or how they're doing currently before I move on to further highlights. Anything from your end?
Ah.
Yeah, no, they're still doing amazing. As of this week and starting on Friday, actually, we added their phones to the phone queue. So they're now getting support calls coming in that they can pick up and answer and work on right away as well. So everything's been going great.
Yeah, they just told me about that. Yeah, thank you for sharing that. Yeah, and they acknowledged, so honestly, they acknowledged that we'll be reviewing on the following slide that the ticket result rate needs to improve to meet ITBD target.
Yeah.
monthly or we can say daily, weekly or monthly target. However, both of them find the team up to USA environment very supportive. So they love working with you. Thank you.
Moving on to performance analysis and in comparison to a week previous to that. So in April, from April 27th to May 1st, this is the total utilization that shows Phoebe's available utilization as 76.43% and non-available remain 16%.
16.93 percent. So the total comes to 93.35 percent.
And she remained a little bit on the higher side. Previously, Phoebe was at 100% mark, and this time she was close to 97.3, 98%. So his billable remain 83.65% and non-billable.
13.15%.
So...
What I capture from this, that you know, why billable or what is the cause of this, you know, billable not reaching too, you know, because I want this to be higher. I mean, sure is doing fine. 83% is a good number, but Phoebe 76.43.
So I checked some of the some of the issues previously they said they were they were handling they were managing PMI tickets mostly.
Mhm.
All right, so now there's a shift from PMI to user support, as I highlighted. I can show on the next slide as well. So here I mentioned from PMI to user support. So they both are handling more of end user support tickets, 365.
Addy, some of the networking issues that covers VPN related issues or something similar, and yeah, is always doing handling the same thing, end user 365 printer, so which is why, and one interesting thing, I'm sure you're aware, they they said.
Phelps.
Ticket resolved it, first of all, this number, because sometimes when they do not find a user, they call the user and so they said the caller ID shows something else.
Yeah, we're trying to get that fixed. We've seen this happen at some of our customers as well. When we migrated phone systems and ported phone numbers over, for some reason, this name, Walter, got stuck on the caller ID. Yep, yep.
Mhm.
Walter Hanson.
But.
Yeah, so our team's been working with Zoom Support to try and get that resolved. They're telling us we have to reach out to phone carriers because it's something that's like stuck out there, but it's a work in progress. But yep, Phoebe's brought that up.
Mhm.
Yeah, so when I asked her, you know, the following that I can tell you, the why, you know, you're unable to close, I mean, four to five tickets in a day. I mean, there's always a lag to share. She's shared that when I call and, you know, after reaching to the user.
twice or thrice, you know, he or she shared that. Whenever you call, so it shows, you know, as you know, or aware, so Walter Hanson shows up. So which is why I'm having ignored that call and we do not pick it up. We do not realize it's coming from Optum USA. So, and some of the users, I mean, they didn't respond, so.
Yeah.
So, they follow the they follow the process of a three-strike policy that you that you have, and we everyone follows.
Uh-huh.
If the user is not found, which is why it affects, I mean, they cannot close that ticket same day. And so ultimately, it shows a lower ticket resolution, you know, for that particular day. So that's a major cause. Apart from that, I think they are doing good.
Mm-hmm.
Any thoughts from your end?
Nope, all that makes sense. They've communicated the same thing, so everything's good.
Thank you. One observation for my end as well. So I observed on one ticket because I also want to make sure they are able to resolve user facing tickets, I mean, Helpdesk tickets in a lesser time within 32
40 minutes max. So in some of the tickets, two or three tickets, I found it took longer than usual. So this is my observation. So I checked with, so which is why I'm mentioning here the ticket number printer issue that she attended the other day. I think this was on April the 27th. So I asked him, so he said,
I, because our emphasis is when they're not able to resolve what particular issue is, so they should always include next level after 35 to 40 minutes. So that, I mean, they should not be just keep on trying different different steps. It makes the user, it impacts the user experience overall.
Mhm.
So, she explained that, yes, he did communicate to the internal team, and so, and because why this issue took longer, it was a printer issue, printer, you know, cause you know, this printer issue, because the server, the servers had rebooted.
In the client environment, and and also it affected five other users, so he said I had to work with five different users on that ticket, so which is why I'm in, and later on we found out the issue was not with with their machines or internet environment, so we had to take vendor support.
Mm.
on the call and ultimately it took over 4 hours to fix this. So because vendor support also took more than 1 1/2 to two hours to fix this. So that was an unusual situation, but just wanted to ensure that your team is on track and whenever they need assistance, they're voicing out, they're raising hands so that.
Yeah.
you know, support is always given to them. They should always reach out to me first, if in case uptime you as a team is busy, so that we or someone else in my team here can assist them so that they can resolve tickets in a timely manner.
Okay.
Thank you.
So, I think, so this thing can be improved later on. I mean, once we have, we have, you know, hold on the users.
Moving on to ITBD service offerings. So yeah, as Rick must have communicated this to you, so this is nothing but the same thing. Yeah, one is AI accelerator, which was, which is already, you know, passed. This is build it live event.
It happens every year. So this is ITBD event that we organize every year. So I know this is far away from California to East Side, New Jersey, but if you or someone can make it to this event, that would be great.
By doing this.
Yeah, me and Ketan are going to try to attend. I have some vacation that's a little up in the air around that time that I don't know if I'll be taking or not. If not, then I'll definitely be there. And then one of the owners and board members of uptime, I think, might be attending as well. So we'll have a presence there one way or another.
Mm-hmm.
That's great. Thank you. Yeah, previously on Kasei went as well, so one of your members of board of directors, Sam, I believe. So yeah, he confirmed that to me that, you know, he attended that event. I'm sure he must have met with some of our team members there.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Yeah, thank you.
Because, you know, usually we connect virtually, but when we get to spend time, you know, a few hours with each other, we get to know more requirements and everything, business strategies, and many more. I'm sure it makes it born a little stronger. Thank you.
Mhm.
I think I don't have to touch much on team GPS. You already aware. Whenever you think there's a requirement, you can scan the QR code and team will let you know about this. And so AI by design, I didn't think I have to touch much on this. So you must have received separate email on that as well.
Yep.
Yeah?
From our CX Team.
Moving on to ITBD calendar, I don't have to, I don't think I have to touch much on this as well. So this is exactly the same. It's just why I'm keeping this slide so that we always have traction. We always know that what's coming up next. If there is any kind of, because Phoebe from Wednesday onwards, she'll be.
Mhm.
She'll be on PTS. Thank you for approving her PTS, Randy. Thank you very much. She's really, really happy once her PTS got approved because she said she is one of her best friends, you know, whose wedding was paramount for her to attend, which was at a different city.
No.
Hmm.
So I asked her to bring something for me as well as a gift. So she's attending wedding at a different city. So yeah, so every year ITBD does organize India party as well. But we have on this day specifically.
Haha.
Diwali in November, so that is our winter season in India as well. So Sunny, who is the owner, co-founder of this business, so Sunny, Cam, and many other stakeholders from the US team, the Wizard India during that time. And yeah, we just...
Mm.
you know, shake a leg, you know, together, dine, and yeah, we enjoy it together during that time. So this will be near Diwali this year as well.
Before our emphasis, for at least for now, is continue to be.
on keeping the focus on meeting KPIs. So that's should and Phoebe should always be learning wherever they think there's a gap, there is something that is taking time to fix issues. So they must, you know, highlight that and take training. We do have
Well, ITBD University here, where they can always register themselves for a particular course and attend themselves.
Mm.
And my focus is to encourage them to support any improvement where they think they need assistance so that I can help them and so they continue to add value in your environment. And yeah, as I shared, so ITBD always organizes our quarterly.
Cheers over at the dinner of the team from our end from the TTLs side.
When I sit with my team, we often, I mean, sometimes team decides, why not, you know, we ordered some pizza, you know, this Friday. So this is what we do, small activities in the office, so that, I mean, we can sit for 20 or 30 minutes together and
Okay.
You know, spend some good time and understand each other better. This is what we do.
Mhm.
That's me off on my end. I quickly finished my presentation. Let me share my screen. Again, anything that you think must be there on this slide and probably I did not cover. I would love to include that.
I can't think of anything.
Okay.
Mm.
Kevin, over to you. Anything from your end?
No, I'm good. Just wanted to keep a check on the new additions, Brandy. This month, if everything goes well, we would see uptime part getting expanded from 2 to 4 maybe. So if you need any support or anything that you...
June.
Yep.
Do you mean?
Want to know, as per, you know, the additions, do do let us know.
Will do. Thank you.
Yep, well, rest, I'm good. Thanks A lot.
Okay, I think, although we started late, but thank you for everyone's cooperation. Brandy, we still finished on time, I mean at least 3 minutes before.
Okay.
All right, so thank you, Team, for joining in. And although I mean, Randy, we do meet, you know, on this weekly call every time, but please feel free to share anything that comes in between. And I think I did see that we have Teams Federation also open. So for anything, I mean, anything, something important or maybe miscellaneous,
Yeah.
Will you be available if I reach out to you to ask something? Would that be a good channel, Team Federation? Okay. No, thank you. Hi, Michelle. Thank you for joining in.
Yeah, that's fine.
I think you were busy on some other commitments. Yeah.
Very good evening, Brandy.
No, I was just trying to wrap my dates already 5 o'clock. I just jumped in to say hi to Brandy and Hope things are going fine. Gagan is there, Kavan is there. I don't have much to add from my side. Just a quick thing. I'm sure Ron from ITBD is reaching out to you regarding the build it.
Yeah.
Yes.
Right, so again, I don't have to add much, but this group is there in case if you have any question apart from Ron, like that you want to ask about build it, we would love to see you over there. So you're coming there? Ah, great. Again, I'm late. So that is fantastic. That is fantastic. So team will be really, really happy to see you over there.
Yeah.
He's coming to build it, Vishal.
Mm.
I'm here in case if you have any question along with Gagan, Kavan and Gagan, so this team is here to help you out. So again, great to see you and have a good rest of the day, Brandy.
Yep, you too. Thank you.
Yeah, thank you, Brandy, for joining in and thank you, Team. It was a pleasure meeting you again. Thank you.
All right. Thanks everyone. Bye bye.
Thanks a lot. Thank you, Brandy. Take care. Bye-bye.
Thank you so much. Take care. Bye.
Thank you. Bye-bye.